welcome back to the Rich Eisen show most
receptions by a rookie running back in a
single season most hundred yards at
least games from scrimmage by a rookie
we can go on and on and on you wonder
why my next guest had such a great first
season well the eye test says he has a
god-given talent Old Spice would say he
was properly moisturized and exfoliated
when he was running the football and
catching it for the New York Football
Giants good to see you say Quan bardelli
good to see you yeah how are you
but that's an applause line as well how
are you doing good I think you said it
best okay but just here talking about
the new fresher collection it does does
it hold on now you have the product
right here don't you guys I have the
product right here which by the way Old
Spice is big God look oh they're beaming
look I'm holding the product we're
talking about the product and I don't
want it for free I'm just gonna chow I'm
gonna give it the smell test here well
that does smell great incident smells
real it smells like it hasn't been put
together by some form of machine or
anything like that it feels like you've
picked whatever fruits are in there
personally say come on it's what it
feels like why were you playing
difference at the Pro Bowl what are you
doing man having fun enjoying it you
know you don't know how many times you
gonna get back there I know most people
in the league that only every minute
once so I've never been there before
okay so I'm God just live in a moment
and went back to my high school roots I
never was a defensive end played a
little outside linebacker got a pass
pressure by the way in high school no in
the pro in the game and a probe on the
stat sheet I hope so
I intense - I hope so deshaun Watson was
Owen - when I was in a game you know oh
my god you know I get a little package
in there so he just left unfortunately
otherwise I'd passed that smack-talk you
look Brock Mineta statue to make sure
say Quan Barkley got the past pressure
that he's so proud of let me ask you
while he's looking that up did you hear
from Shermer or anybody saying why are
you playing defense in this game did you
hear it all from them oh no no obviously
they they know that would be at least
smart
myself in harm's way um it would just go
out there have a fun chop with a show
for the fans okay I'm in like I said you
live in a moment and just having a blast
see the fact that you did not hear from
your coach your owners means you've got
some juice in this leaves aha I'm just
helping you out right now you've got
some juice why all I hear from rookies
in the 16 plus years that I've done the
NFL Network is that the speed of the
game is tough to adjust to it seems like
you were able to adjust to it is that an
appropriate reaction you know yeah
everyone say the speed is different you
know I've been quoted saying I don't I
don't believe in that if you run a four
three we run a 4-3 if you're on a 440
104 for no matter if it's in college
orbs and then about your speed right
obviously it changes with time and we
age but if you run for 300 for three I
would say just the difference is the
preparation that you actually get to put
in in college you've got so much
schoolwork and NFL you have nothing but
time to put in preparation and I got
guys like Luke Kuechly who can come up
and call your place and Tom's just off
what he see off film and his scope that
happened to you I don't know us but I
remember seeing like his NFL top 100 or
something like that
thank you for watching and I filmed that
by the way shake one thing for that
promotion you know he seen him doing
that so they just react and the scheme
and the defense and ain't nobody needed
B so that's quicker so you have to you
have to you know be better in your
preparation and your studying a film so
you can be a step ahead also too it's
not the speed that's a different sorry
that's all I can manhandle the
microphone like you did defenses that's
right
so when if I'm not mistaken I also saw
picked up by an NFL Films mic you
calling your own play in a way where you
realized I forget which team was again
those are the Redskins Washington would
you realize what a defense the front
that you were seeing that if you saw it
again let's do this play and you took it
to the house yeah it wasn't so much me
calling the play that the coach called
the play and his put us in a great
position I would just me just
communicating with off as a line I think
that's a big thing and in sports and
football especially in my position to be
successful Communications offensive line
and what they're saying what I'm singing
a front and I was I was what I was
saying how the defense was attacking me
what they were trying to do and
I was trying to lean and set him up one
way and I was telling a Jomon if you
would be able to hook them then I'll be
able to just be one with the safety and
I'll take care of that and that's what
you got to do as a runner but you know
you got one you want to want sometimes
people gonna make some tackles but you
got one most of them say Kwan Barclay
here on the Rich Eisen show care of Old
Spice and the New York Football Giants
here on the show is it true your dad's a
jet fan yes I mean such a Jets fan that
he has a Jets tattoo right here when did
he get that ink was that was he inspired
by Richard Todd's play in the 70s or
what was it Ray Lucas in the 90s that
caused your dad to get that ank-ooo what
was it Jesus or anything about my dad
and being a Jets fan and I was once a
Jets fan now definitely a Giants fan
1969 go on the first AFC team won a
Super Ball the year my dad was born born
in New York growing up everyone loved
the Giants probably a little bit more so
he kind of just went the other way being
John's fan he kind of passed it on to me
so I grew up being a fan of Curtis
Martin Thomas Jones Chad Pennington the
Mark Sanchez era with Rex Ryan and those
guys so I think he kind of got it
probably maybe like when the March since
his era was going I don't think he did
it cuz of that sure he always had a
passion he always want to do it and one
day just made up his mind he said he's
gonna put it just tattoo it I don't know
what I'm freaking out about more the
fact that you could be a jet you were
living and dying with the Jets while I
was living and dying with the Jets or
that your dad and I were born in the
same year and you could be my son and
I've got a ten almost 8:00 to 5:00 at
home and this is not about me it's about
you safe so was your dad disappointed
that the Jets didn't take you know oh my
dad was happy that you know he see their
son living it or didn't get a chance to
take you oh yeah yeah but he was happy
just like I'm saying his son he's him
and my mother very fortunate to have
both parents in my life you know I've
always went to them and told them what I
want to do and what I'm passionate about
I know it was gaming great advice
and I try to show me the way what I got
to do to get to my dream and live out my
dream so when I got my name called mine
it could have been the Patriots it could
have been whoever and my dad and parents
gonna be happy for I'll see my dad
probably would like me to be going to
the Jets but being close to home being
New York you know I can actually nothing
better yeah and you know for me to say
this you know that it was I you know I'm
disappointed you weren't a jet also what
could be construed that I'm not happy
that Sam Donald was the one who was
taken by the Jets and obviously he's
very good I I'm wondering how you
respond to this but I'll ask it anyway I
can kind of figure it out but I'll ask
it anyway you heard the conversation
throughout the season that Giants fans
should have taken Eli's replacement
that's what they were saying that John
should take any large replacement
instead of you how do you respond to
something like that um I'm the way I was
raised my parents said it's people
that's always gonna have something good
to say about you and those people that's
going up something bad to say about you
so I don't really get bothered by that
comment mom I said is that it is what it
is and the Giants took me I have my own
expectations in my own standards and I'm
gonna come in to every single day ready
to work and try to lead my team to a
championship okay and I and a scale of
one to ten one being very sane ten being
crazy
where does odell wind up on that scale
ode oh man Adele's Odell and that's not
a number yeah yeah
let me see craziness
he just passion he's just a passionate
person I'm talking about on a field off
the field
very loving hard worker you know this
there's so many good things that I say
bond but the best thing I could say
about him is he's one of the first guys
when I kind of came to the draft process
that contact martin wing we kind of
showed me the ropes um he'd been through
it all he's seen through he's seen it
all and he knew where I was gonna go
through so definitely fortunate enough
to have him as the best friend of my
life see that's why you're so good for
the New York market you handled both of
those questions definitely very well
thank you can run a hand catch pretty
much you know so I mean in Brockman knew
Chris Rock went over there you can
answer this question with Odell what
soon as he came off the campus of LSU
well man love right I mean we're very
smitten
well we being the Royal way you and I
together but I mean yeah that's what I
mean you don't I mean but yeah in terms
of collegiately over the last several
years who would that be
for me Joey Joey sake one Barclay that's
a fact
that's a fact i watch the show you give
me a long-- phrase know you have seen
that right I'm shocking cuz you're in
Michigan well look why would that be
shopping for shocking I mean we're we're
they tell you four big ten they tell you
talked about how the speed of the game
and the NFL did not phase you that's
understandable coming from the Big Ten
that's Michigan defense Ohio State
defense we're an SEC country where it
means so much more to all the fans that
are here part me out but I'm
appreciative of all you focus mid LAN is
showing up here but yes he come on right
I can I can talk about that all day I
know I could there is a southeast bias
when it comes to college football right
I believe that you know my personal pin
it's a lot of great teams in college but
you know when you separate the top-tier
SEC teams and separate the top tier the
Big Ten teams yes I think in last four
or five years obviously with the
exception of Alabama and Clemson as well
I mean oh yeah definitely Clemson I
would say you know the 10 is if not
better just as good how much do you all
hate Ohio State you know it's all has
state more than Michigan actually I hate
them all like I don't understand because
I've said I never even go to I ain't
gonna say of Michigan but we don't got
to hate for you know those same thing to
two teams away you guys got hate for
each other so you jealous of our hate no
you know you got like something that's
cool about Penn State I'm like we kind
of like like two whole like we like hold
our head up high like were Penn State
like people won't be alright was but we
don't mind I guess you can't say Ohio
State has kind of came into that at the
last three or four games we had were out
of state either a last-second plays or
too many drives were win or black fill
go probably in the last three years
top 10 games in college football so
definitely got no hate just mutual
respect
but I thought Akron's your rival I
thought that your coach said Super Bowl
everyone's equivalent to a team like
Akron
that's our mana said the Super Bowl
whoever we faced that week
does a great job you are so good at this
James Franklin that whole thing like
that
so okay couple more questions for you
sake one I'm gonna see tres McSorley at
the combine right yeah okay and
everybody's talking about undersized
quarterbacks Baker did this and we're
talking about calamari how come we're
not talking about tres in the NFL what
do you think you I think you know
everyone's gonna say what they want to
say like I said if you're gonna say good
things and bad things about you and you
could say what you want to say about
race well I did I could say about race
is a competitor I'm not even talking
about a winner talking about a
competitor and at the end of the day
when you see it on fl-eye right uh
surround myself with guys who's gonna
compete no matter what no matter for
down 30 or up 30 if we're three and 13
over 13 and three that shows who you
really are and he showed that time at
the time at the time in college being
heard playing through injuries
everyone always saying that there was
whole life he can't do this he can't do
that and prove him wrong and I'm a firm
believer in tres McCoy and I believe
that once he gets NFL no matter where he
gets drafted whether it's high whether
it's not when he gets on my team is
gonna prove himself
Ryan you know though he pulls that
homerun routine in the end I felt
someone's gonna come high and tight he's
gonna get a brush back I mean they tried
to did a little bit in college but he'll
do it more than I do it trust me okay
and did you have an aha moment welcome
the NFL because again it seemed like you
handled it so expertly did you have one
of those moments where like okay yeah a
couple won the first game of the year
you're going to Jackson of defense who
won best defense in the league or
definitely coming from the prior season
to that you got coleus cannon most Smith
Jalen Ramsey and so on and so on you see
those guys and to be able to have
success against them and I game and then
probably my hit welcome to the NFL hit
was JJ Watt we were running like a
counter play to the left and he beat one
of our guys to the right so like this is
Virgil original eyes that we're going to
left he beats the guys to the right and
hits me at the same time when I'm
getting a ball so I was just like wow
like that's impressive and then the best
moment was ap you know to have that
moment after the game and for him to
take the time leaders yeah yeah to look
me too I just as a man and just me being
a big fan of him and being him being a
fan of my game and telling me that all
the greats out there wants me
go be the best and go do it and there's
room for me my so much of me and then
you were properly moisturized and
exfoliated the entire strap definitely
what's with the fanny pack that you've
got the right there it's like the new
that's a new thing I'm trying you know
yo see like rock with the turtleneck
like the rock picture with the turn
naked okay back sure China like you know
I'll see if any fat coming I'm trying
like come back mom so the say Quan fanny
pack and I might go like a bigger like
do so like when you look at fanny packs
is probably fits better on skinny guy so
I'm like trying to shows like muscular
guys like we can do that too so yeah I
mean I got no idea Mike I mean would you
yeah it was a fanny pack yeah you mind
would you mind before you go come can he
try on the fanny of course it's not
gonna fit around me yeah but I mean it's
I guarantee you that's not an XXL I mean
I think we can give that a try
for sure I think we take say Quan thanks
for coming on Old Spice I got the Old
Spice moisturize with shea butter body
wash they are real ingredients that you
could see him right here on on the on
the I guess the cover of a right on the
front of it at se Quan on Instagram and
Twitter as well
I follow you I just don't know if I get
a follow back Wow I mean I think I do
actually not sure but I think I do
did he get us past did he get his pass
brushed
no no I'm not I'm actually watching the
hit JJ Watt put on you basically took
the hand off Wow well it's a hell of a
baptism though and if you get one in the
NFL isn't that that's that's new no
better mo better got a baptized your
great to see a say Kwan been a fan for a
while great to have you on the show
don't be a stranger
of course we should I'd see Quan Barkley
everybody right here on the rich
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience